Speaker 1: Let's go next to
Mark from Los Angeles. Mark,
welcome. You guys are getting
a crazy heat wave, right?
Hellboy. Mark from Los Angeles.
You were on the air. Welcome, Mark.
Speaker 2: Hello. Hello? Yes. Oh, hey. Hi.
Hi. Sorry I freaked out the second with the.
Yeah, well, I wanted to compliment you because I.
Thought that sure interview with the was a I think
it was a candidate the conspiracy theory guy.
Speaker 1: Might CARGILE.
Speaker 2: That was his saying it was crazy
it was I was like wow.
Speaker 1: I don't know
if you saw Mark, but Mike Pillow was so
triggered by that interview that he sent
dozens of messages on Facebook in the comments
to that interview, to my viewers and to me.
Speaker 2: He probably related to the
the ideas and thought that this man,
this clearly very rational thinker.
Speaker 1: Yes, exactly.
Speaker 2: Unfairly smeared by you. Right. So
speaking of conspiracy theories, I was wondering,
have you heard of birds aren't real?
Speaker 1: Yes, absolutely.
Speaker 2: Have you ever thought
of interviewing those guys? No.
Speaker 1: I mean, it's it's satire. And we don't
you know, the couple of times we've done satirical
interviews on the show, they don't go well because
half the audience doesn't get that. It's satire,
and then the other half does and thinks it's
not really that interesting. So that's why we
usually don't do the satire interviews. I did an
interview. What's the name of the candidate who
puts the boot on his head and promises people
free ponies? You know who I'm talking about.
Speaker 2: That before in my life. And that sells.
Speaker 1:
Hold on. Candidate free pony boot
on head. What's the guy's name?
Okay, hold on. Here it is. His name is Vermin
Supreme. I interviewed him and like he says,
it's not satirical, but, like, if it's
not satirical, then he's nuts. Yeah, I
don't know. It just doesn't seem to fit the show.
Speaker 2: Okay. Okay. This is just like the funny
thing is, I, you know, I don't know if you saw the
60 Minutes interview. That was really great. No.
Yeah. They got covered on 60 Minutes, which is
a big, big step for them, but that's huge. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. They I when I saw this, I
was like, I have to have a shirt, right.
I'm. I must have a shirt. And so I put the
shirt on and I work with a lot of people who
some of them have conspiracy theories. And
literally I'm going and they're reading like
birds aren't real. And they tell me, yeah, you
know, birds aren't really you noticed like the
left wing in the right wing, you know,
and president speak to people to tweet
and they land on power lines. So power
lines are just recharging stations for
the birds and. Right, right. People believe it.
Speaker 1: It's hallmark. It sounds like quite a
party, but we'll look into it for sure.
Speaker 2: We're quite
sure you've used the term and I love it. What is
it? It's not out of a cannon before this person
shot out of the cannon. Where do you get that
from? It sounds like something like a parent
would say about a child or something like that.
Speaker 1: You know, I think I got it from Howard
Stern. Really. I for some reason, I feel
like I haven't listened to him for years,
but I feel like it's something he
would sometimes say when, you know,
someone would come in, like elegant Elliot
often and he'd be shot out of a cannon.
Speaker 2: Okay. Yeah, I get it. I get it
because it just to me, it sounds like something
like a parent. You come in here from school,
shot out of the can and calm down. Yeah, well.
Speaker 1: Listen, Mark, you're shot out
of a cannon, and I'm up against the break,
so I'm gonna let you go, okay?
Speaker 2: All right. Have a
good one. Thank you so much. I love your show.
Speaker 1: All right, thanks. Mark. Mark from
l.a. We're going to take a quick break and then
go right back to the phones. If you're holding,
don't hang up because there will be more
opportunities to chat in just a moment.